there's a Times article times magazine
article by Jesse Ferguson which points
out quite eloquently something that I've
been saying for I mean I guess since
November 9th the day after the November
8th presidential election which is
president elect Donald Trump has the
biggest non mandate of any recent
president not by a little bit but by a
very very long shot recall that Donald
Trump won the electoral vote because of
just under sixty thousand votes across
three states Trump although he is using
the word major win mandate etc Trump won
with fewer electoral votes than Barack
Obama in 2012 and actually way way way
fewer electoral votes than Barack Obama
in 2008 and recall that even President
Obama's overwhelming electoral vote win
in 2008 wasn't enough for them to get
together the day after the he was either
the day after the election of the day
after the inauguration of President
Obama to his first term to say we are
going to obstruct by any means necessary
if obstruction made sense after that
overwhelming win then progressives
absolutely need to get together to
prevent the Donald Trump agenda which
were increasingly learning about as a
globalist Pro oligarch agenda they need
to get together and so in addition to
Trump's meager electoral vote win
remember that almost three million more
people voted for Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump Hillary Clinton won the
popular vote by a bigger margin than
John F Kennedy in his 1960 presidential
win by a bigger margin than Richard
Nixon in his 1968 presidential win and
in addition to this we have the CIA and
the FBI agreeing at this point on the
assessment that Russian hacking at the
direction of Russian President Vladimir
Putin intervened to help the election in
favor of Donald Trump and against
Hillary Clinton even if you don't
believe that part and I know that there
are skeptics who don't necessarily agree
with that assessment of the FBI and CIA
right now forget about that and
sitter the reality that Donald Trump
aside from Russian hacking has the
largest non mandate we've seen in a long
time and also even if you look at the
Congressional level yes Republicans
control Congress there's no doubt about
it
despite though which should be illegal
gerrymandering in congressional
districts which makes it so difficult as
I've told you before for Democrats to
take control of the House Democrats
still managed to pick up six seats in
the House trumpets will hear me talking
about this though and they'll say David
this is sour grapes you guys lost make
America great again you're a [ __ ] etc
etc blah blah blah this conversation
isn't for the trumpets I know that they
are there but this conversation is for
the for the sane and reasonable
progressives in our audience there is a
basis here a factual basis for doing
everything we can to stop Donald Trump
from carrying out his harebrained ideas
and Republicans depend on progressives
internalizing Oh Trump crushed us he
slaughtered us he won a mandate and now
we have no choice but to let the
Republicans do whatever they want for
four years or potentially for eight
years that is only going to be the case
if progressives allow it to be the case
can't fall victim to that can't fall
victim to what Republicans are trying to
do a majority of Americans rejected the
agenda of the current Republican regime
Trump talks about a mandate Trump's
transition team member Sean Spicer is
all over corporate media touting a
mandate that does not exist Republicans
won the right to govern but there is no
mandate for their policies and in fact
it's quite the opposite their platform
was by and large rejected by voters
across the country we recognize this I
recognize this
and we recognize the urgency and the
need for progressives to coordinate and
organize and that's why we're running a
$60,000 crowdfunded fundraiser right now
which I'll talk about later I've talked
about before reminder though david
pakman.com slash donate is the play
to learn more about that I'm gonna take
a break I'm on Twitter at D Pakman talk
to me about what we see as the biggest
non mandate for a president in a very
very long time on on Twitter at D Pakman
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated